hi everyone this is Luca I guess you
know me this is my channel and here we
are with czy hi nice to nice to see you
again hi thank you for inviting me my
pleasure so czy is a wonderful language
learner and Creator um she has been
creating a lot of interesting material
for Hungarian Learners and uh for me
it's been uh it's been a boon in the
sense it's been great to have these
materials especially because back in the
day I think even you started 5 years ago
or something like that to produce
producing material right yeah exactly
there was not a lot of stuff and so that
for me um you know the kind of material
that you produce is just been amazing
but on top of that you're also a
language learner and today we're going
to talk about something really
interesting which is limiting beliefs
something that not a lot of people talk
about and especially in you know in the
language learning system more school and
we want to address this as language
creators and uh YouTubers and most of
all language Learners so first of all uh
can you could you please briefly
introduce yourself and tell us uh what
you do and then we're going to delve
into the limiting
beliefs yeah of course uh I'm Cece and
I'm a Hungarian s a second language
teacher uh as Luca said I started to
teach uh 5 years ago and um since then
it has been my full-time job and I
create material for Hungarian learners
for self-study and I try to uh create
content about um how to study on your
own basically that's the that's the main
goal of uh uh my business and uh I also
learn uh
languages uh I'm studying Spanish at the
moment that's the most active because I
live in the United States my husband is
Mexican so so that's the that's the big
motivation here and I studied polish and
Russian at
University and uh well I haven't really
used them for a while but I still
occasionally listen to some podcasts and
it's it's nice to hear the language but
I I haven't talked neither in Polish
neither in Russian for a while
unfortunately I guess it's not that easy
to to use polish and Russian in Texas
right you don't just like in the corner
say hey speak Russian or polish yeah
anyway yeah um I understand uh it's
normal and you know there's some
languages that we use more for our life
circumstances the languag we use less
anyway so uh thank you very much uh for
the introduction and let's delve into
the limiting beliefs so you've been a
language learner for quite some time and
I would like to to know how like can you
tell me tell me and uh the rest of the
gang um your limiting beliefs some 20
years ago when you started learning
languages and you're or 10 years ago
even and um how they changed uh you know
uh in with
time oh my God I have or I had I don't
know I still have so
many it was really hard to choose some
but um let's see the first one that I
would say and
um that I just uh recently came over is
that I cannot say anything until I'm
fluent I'm pretty sure I'm not the only
one who struggles struggled with this
one and how did I overcome it well I
still have really really bad days when I
feel like I cannot say anything because
my grammar is not going to be good
because I don't know how to say it in a
in a nice way and I'm going to sound
like a child and stuff like that but
what really helped me overcome it most
of the time is talking to my
father-in-law because he doesn't speak
English so um I recommend uh finding
someone who doesn't speak uh uh your
native language or English or whatever
and that's the only language you can
speak with them that you're learning
that that helps that pushes you you
don't have a choice so and then it's a
really good experience you know
to um to to experience that it's not a
bad grammar I I got to know so many
things about my father-in-law we had
such fun conversations I know so much
about him about his childhood about his
hobes now because because I tried to
speak Spanish and he didn't care about
my grammar if
the point was to
communicate I love it he didn't care
about my grammar the point was to
communicate because you had no other
choice right so um just a brief comment
about that this is like the all of
nothing limiting belief right like
sometimes you you speak and sometimes
you find it difficult and you think it's
either this or that or I'm not a good uh
speaker so um that's one example and uh
you're right there's many there's so
many limiting beliefs that we had and we
still have but I think that the point
the point that you're making is once you
live it once you experience it once you
actually live and breathe and you go
through it and realize it's just a
figment of your mind as they say it's
like everything everything else I think
in language learning and not only
language learning our mind and our
thoughts shape our
reality this is a little bit
philosophical but it's true thank you
for sharing I'm reading from my a couple
of questions I jutted down from my
iPhone here um so
uh could you share please a specific uh
experience where you confronted a
challenging belief about language
learning and how did that change your
approach to teaching and learning
languages because on top of creating
language learning material you you've
also teach or you taught Hungarian for
quite some time you also organize Zoom
meetings uh and I'm ashamed to say um
that I still haven't participated but I
would like to because it look very
interesting about very interesting
topics so um how did that overcoming one
specific belief uh help you as a
language Creator as a teacher as a
language learner and everything in
between yeah if I had to choose one
thing I think that would
be um first the language and then
grammar or the other way around at the
beginning so that's how we were taught
at school that's how I started to teach
as well that first we learn the grammar
and then we try to use it or we don't
even try to use it we just learn Lear a
lot of grammar because why not and
then um and that's how I was teaching
too when I still gave private lessons
and this started to switch when I
started to learn Spanish and this was
the first language that I started to
learn on my own uh no school no teachers
nothing I found a language exchange
partner uh I mean he was a teacher too
which was good because he knew how to
talk to me at my level
because when you're a beginner talking
to a native speaker I don't think that's
going to be too much help but in my case
it helped a lot because he knew how to
talk to me at my level so then uh my
goal was to speak as fast as poss Okay C
so that was your first limiting belief
do you have do you have any other
limiting
belief yeah I have so many so the other
one would be switching to English is
cheating um I felt this so so many times
and then I have to remind myself that
English is also a language that I
learned and I hate it that everyone
always says that but that's easy and
everyone speaks English well neither of
them is true in my
opinion and um what
else
um a third one for example I know you
have many but give me three the the most
the most important limiting beliefs okay
um then let me choose one that comes
from school because I have so many
because of school the the way we learned
we were taught is
that I don't know for
example watching movies is not studying
and that is a reward after the real
studying that that's what uh uh what I
thought for the longest time and I
actually remember I have a memory of uh
of a teacher telling me this at school
when she asked me if I studied Russian
yesterday if I did my homework and I
told her which movies I watched and she
told me that but did you study before
cuz first comes the real actual
studying and um this this idea that if
you watch a movie you have to sit down
and look up every word and analyze every
sentence like why I don't know I watched
Naros in Spanish and I learned so many
words cuz they repeat so many things and
uh they say I don't know
s 200 times within one episode and I
learned how to say that in the
imperative why is that bad I think
that's something good
no agree um agree I think I think the
main point um or the main takeaway uh is
that at school we tend to learn the
language learning is more like homework
it's something that we must do instead
of something we want to do and it's
something that is not necessarily
Pleasant like oh you first have to do uh
you know the homework and then maybe you
can reward yourself watching a movie
while the reward like the actual study
should also be the reward that's how we
also learn and speaking of which um I
don't want to flatter you but the
reality is that one of the reasons why I
continue learning Hungarian was that
when I listen to your podcast I feel
like there's a friend who's telling me
about her life and this gives me an idea
of like oh I'm enjoying this it's not
even studying it's just listening to
someone telling hey well in childhood I
did this and I did that and we tend to
forget when we come out of 10 years of
school we tend to forget languishing can
be real pure pleasure if we want them to
be you know if you want if we want this
to be this way so thank you for sharing
I agree with everything you said and I
these were also my limited beliefs
before I got out and you know lower
languages by myself let me read some
other couple of questions I have here on
my iPhone so uh you share three limiting
beliefs there's many I'm pretty sure we
can write a long list um could you share
a specific experience where you
confronted a challenging belief about
language learning and how did that
change your approach to teaching and
learning languages I want to remind uh
those who are listening to us that um
you know cc is not just a language
learner she's also a language Creator
and she was and still is a language
teacher uh I think you still organize
these Zoom meetings uh once in a month
and uh you know within your school or
your online activity you get to do a lot
of things listening to podcasts watching
videos talking to people and everything
in between right so please tell us about
how confront confronting one limiting
belief has changed the perspective you
have towards teaching and learning in
general yeah if I had to choose one
thing uh that would be first the
language and then the grammar this this
concept because um I'm
sorry because in school first we learned
grammar right um and and then we try to
use it or we don't even try to use it we
just learn grammar just more and more
grammar and um and that's how I was
teaching at the beginning as well when I
still gave private lessons because I
didn't know any better and uh um yeah we
learned the I don't know past tense the
conjugation present tense imperative and
stuff like that and then we try to use
them in example sentences that no one
would ever say in their
lives and I don't know I I saw the same
pattern that every
student uh knows so much about the
language and cannot say anything in the
language or don't even really understand
the language and I'm not saying that
grammar is not needed at all but what I
realized is I think that it should be
like a good good balance of the language
and grammar of course you can look up
things if you want to know more about
them if you want to understand them more
but I think first the language has it it
has first the language has to come so
why do you want to know this grammar
because you heard something in a podcast
that you want to understand or you had a
conversation and there's this uh
structure that came up so many times
that you feel like you wanted to use but
you're not there yet it's not your level
maybe yet or you just haven't learned it
yet and you really want to know cuz it
was the 10th time that you wanted to use
it then sure look it up learn it cuz
this something you're going to need but
just learning every single form every
single ending so then maybe when you
know everything in 20 years then maybe
then you can form your first sentence
that's
crazy so I have so many op so many
comments uh I just I I'll be very brief
uh you're absolutely right this is one
of the most important things I will put
a link in the description box Box about
a beautiful speech by a guy I think he's
Mexican his name is Guzman and if you
write Guzman Tech talk speak English you
will hear the whole you will listen to
the whole speech beautiful and he talks
about he addresses this main point that
he was trying to teach English and to
teach to his kids and uh they were
saying uh no menra no no it doesn't fit
in my head he like Mexican kids learning
English and he came to the conclusion
that first comes um communication then
comes form and form means you talk then
I can correct you give you Corrections
later I can give you feedback later but
first of all you have to focus on
communication not the other way around
LOM we say katoom in general but it's
LOM because in Hungarian you have to
reverse right the name and the surname
and domato used to say that you actually
do not learn um you you learn language
you don't learn language from grammar
but grammar from language is one of the
most famous sentences that she quotes in
yeah my my favorite to in her book how I
learn languages uh so these two things I
wanted to say is really important that
you know we come from years of school
where grammar is at the center first
grammar first language later it's
actually the opposite or a combination
where grammar notes just help you refine
your speech But first you have to
communicate and use the language
wonderful C thank you thank you for
sharing so let me see here third
question how has your uh your own
mindset and belief system influenced
your language learning journey and the
content you create for your YouTube
channel this is a very interesting uh
question CU I want to know what drives
you to create such amazing podcast where
you know you're telling a story you have
the capacity of combined language of
knowing which level right you don't have
a and I said I wonder I often say this
is um let me see if CC put A1 or A2 or
B1 because I I first listen and then I
see how you you know Cate categorize uh
the the level and you have this Capac
of creating content that is perfect for
the specific level that you define and
then it's like you telling a story about
your life basically I know a lot about
you through the podcasts so I don't know
if these the change in your belief
systems has had shaped the way you
create these podcast I'm interested in
knowing
that I think so but you know maybe it
wasn't conscious at the beginning cuz I
don't remember having this great plan or
strategy for building my podcast I just
had this drive I don't
know kind of passion to start it and I
just really wanted to do
it um but even if I wasn't conscious
still the same uh outcome I think
and I don't know I just thought about it
so many times that now there's so many
language teachers on YouTube so much fun
content um
in every language and when I went to
University we had what what did we have
the CD player with the textbook audio so
if I had someone the same age like me a
Polish Girl telling about stuff that I
don't know topics that I would also talk
with talk about with my friends that
would have been so much more interesting
than talking about buying train tickets
or asking someone for or the where do I
find the fitting room and stuff like
that I don't
know absolutely yeah so I think that and
and also what I mentioned um I think I
already mentioned it um my Spanish
language exchange partner when I started
to um learn this way with
him
and and then from these two we ex
streams that only grammar or no grammar
at all I started to arrive somewhere in
the middle finding the balance between
them and and that helped a lot
too um also I feel like sorry yeah no
nothing I I was just I was just thinking
when you were talking that actually uh
maybe it's me but I haven't found I
haven't found any grammar notes like
some some vocabulary list like you
explain some Vo stuff and you had some
uh some stuff like Quizlet or some
exercises but I don't I don't think I
I've seen recently anything in that
regard I might be wrong though maybe you
have them somewhere I haven't seen them
but the grammar stuff I haven't seen
recently uh the way you were presenting
it earlier am I wrong because I think
you also wanted to introduce some
changes I might be wrong yeah I I
already introduced the
changes um few I don't know I actually
don't remember maybe a few weeks ago a
month ago something like that and and I
started to add grammar explanations as
well but I always choose one or two
specific things that I think are
interesting or very useful for that
level so it's never more than two of
these things and sometimes it's not even
grammar sometimes it's explanation of of
a useful word something that has to do
with culture or something like that so I
started to add uh these but I don't want
to overwhelm anyone so but I also know
that people love these but they do that
that's they do so you got to give them
what they
love yes true it's something that you
can have on top of everything but if you
have something like they're they're not
too long and they explain so sometimes
you even explain things in the text you
use a verb or you use a noun and you say
Kai for example well not Kai but Kai
means cool right or or you explain oh
this is a slang word and the equivalent
in you know more refined Hungarian is
this so the explanation the grammar
explanation is already kind of in the
text um anyway I I can tell that you
know you produce stuff you understand it
you get it like from the point of view
of me learning Hungarian you get that
this is something interesting is not a
text but like it's not something that
they made for at you know for school or
for homework so I can tell that this
you know overcoming some limiting
beliefs has uh helped you to shape
wonderful the wonderful material that
you create because it's wonderful anyway
so let me go back to the questions here
there's two more you're most
welcome um so this is a very important
one too I talk about this in my book
many language Learners often struggle
with self-doubt what strategies do you
recommend for your students to overcome
this common limit a belief self-doubt
like I'm not good at language learning
mhm
well
um what I would say it's going to be
very cliche I think but I found that
useful for myself just do it anyway so
try not to what worked for me is not
trying to push this feeling away uh to
me the solution wasn't that wasn't
finding a way how not to doubt myself
but how to do it anyway even if i d
myself like not just try not
to uh take this feeling too seriously
it's there acknowledge that it's there
and but but don't let it stop you
because these feelings don't have to
Define you as a person and what I would
do is positive selft talk something like
I don't know I talk to yourself like I
know you're anxious now but I know you
can do it and instead of repeating these
sentences that uh I'm going to fail I'm
not good enough I suck oh my God what's
going to happen um try to calm yourself
down like how you would talk to a
child or something like that and um and
when and you know when you do it when
you actually I don't know let's try to
find an example order something in
French that you're super scared
of um when you actually do it despite of
feeling like this despite of doubting
yourself that it's going to work out
when you actually do it then it's
evidence for your brain that you can do
this and the more of these you do the
more evidence your brain is going to
have that um you don't have to put so
you don't have to focus too much on how
you feel cuz you can do it despite of
feeling like this that's that's what I
think I love it I love the last sentence
you said about this is evidence for your
brain uh a couple of comments really
quick really quickly because we're
running out of time um I am reading a
very very interesting book I didn't
expect this to be that interesting it's
called change Your Brain Change Your
Life I thought it was just a normal uh
run-ofthe-mill
self-help book self-help book but it's
not it's anything but and one of the
things that uh the author addresses is
positive selft talk uh or cognitive
behavioral therapy um and he re like
when whenever you have a limiting belief
you can you can ask yourself four
questions to reframe it but basically
you know I'm not going to delve into the
questions now but the the the bottom
line is we constantly have negative
thoughts whenever we have a negative
thought address it jut it down uh write
it down and then think about something
that is a the opposite it's a liberating
truth you can always find a liberating
Truth for whatever limiting belief you
have I'm not good at language Journey
well this is not necessarily true uh I
might be not good now but I will be in
the future or many people have learned a
foreign language I can do that too and
the way you shape you see the world
depends on your mindset and the the the
thoughts you have so that's um that's
what I wanted to address first and the
second thing which is which is the point
you touched at the end is so important
is that language learning is about
living it's about talking it's about
communicating with people we have a lot
of doubts because we still don't believe
we can do it then you know even the
smallest interaction like for example
you go to a shop and you you know you
buy something when you're scared
shitless pardon my French of going there
and talking to people then you do this
interaction you realize actually I've
done it I've done it in Polish I've done
it in Russian I've done it in French
whatever it is and then that's evidence
that your brain so this is is experien
is telling subconsciously telling your
brain you can actually do it and this
propels you towards doing things more
and more things okay so I had another
question but this was related to the
last one I asked but again we we can
talk about this briefly uh we often hear
the phrase I'm not just not good at
learning languages something we talked
about how do you challenge this belief
among your your followers encourage a
growth mindset and in general do you
have like we addressed this before but
do you have you know in your in your
community I don't know if there's some
limiting beliefs that people normally
have when it comes to Hungarian
Hungarian is too difficult a difficult
language in the world and how does that
change when you go through your material
and it starts saying oh I can actually
understand your podcast you
know yeah um I think that's the most
common one that Hungarian is the most
difficult language in the world and
honestly if someone is really stuck in
this and wants to hold on hold on to
this um I find it really difficult to
change this belief system in their head
so but if
someone uh wants to change someone wants
to find another way and they feel this
way but they're like there's there might
be something that could help me to
overcome this then you can help then
then I can help with some thoughts
inspiration material guidance whatever
but if someone wants to hold on to this
really tight that that's the most
difficult language it's it's impossible
then maybe I'm not a good teacher I
don't know but I think then it's not
really possible to change that
belief um fa enough fair enough and uh
so
um actually I can only say the same what
you just said uh that they mentioned in
the book two things reframing and asking
yourself questions but good questions so
if you think that instead of saying
Hungarian is really difficult you can
say something like this is taking me a
little bit longer than I expected CU it
might take longer time than learning I
don't know Italian if you're a Spanish
native
speaker um so you can say this is taking
me a little bit longer than I expected
but I'll do my best and I I'll keep
going uh if you keep repeating this
sentence instead of Hungarian is so hard
it's so I hate it so much why is it like
this I hate this so much it's not going
to help you can you can do it it's not
going to help um and asking good
questions I'm going to give you some
examples so if you feel like your
Hungarian is super difficult or just in
general you feel like you're not good at
learning
languages um ask yourself things like um
okay how much time I spend studying uh
Hungarian then if you answer this
question I don't know one hour a week
you have your answer you don't study
enough move on to the next question uh
how often do I study Hungarian every day
or uh once in two weeks then you'll have
your answer again if it's it might not
be about that you're not good enough
maybe maybe just don't spend enough time
on it um then is the material at my
level if the material you're using for
studying is too difficult not good it's
too easy not good so then is it
interesting if you find it boring it's
not good uh how many resources are you
using if you're using more than I don't
know six seven I think that's too much
maybe even five is too
much um use one I'm very one that yeah
that's what I would say too no I mean
just use one always just use one but if
you don't like it you can change it to
another one so I don't mean like stuck
to it forever but as long as you like it
just use one you don't need
more um then I don't know what's your
plan uh or why why don't you have enough
energy how could you have more energy
you can ask yourself super um useful
questions uh instead of just repeating
that hungering is too difficult you
might actually find a solution or
answer yeah wonderful wonderful thank
you very much uh CZ uh for the uh for
this chat I think limiting beliefs are
really really important for all those
who are listening to us if you have any
limiting beliefs maybe you can jot them
down instead of oh you can jot them down
and also uh share them in the comment
section and tell us um tell me Tell Cey
tell the rest of the gang uh what your
limit beliefs were what your limiting
beliefs are right now how you've
overcome it and um you know some of the
limiting beliefs you had because sharing
is living as they say it sounds better
in Spanish sharing is living I don't
know how to say that in Hungarian but it
doesn't matter anyway uh thank you very
much um CeCe can you tell uh the uh the
audience where they can find you what
you're doing you know your YouTube
channel and everything else yeah um you
can find me on Instagram Facebook
YouTube
Spotify every podcast platform it's
Hungarian with CC everywhere written
like szi
szi okay which is CZ is abbreviation for
syvia right syia that's really yes okay
I'll I'll put everything in the
description box and also in I will pin a
comment in the comment section thank you
very much CZ for coming and for uh
sharing your experience and I will see
you guys very soon bye from crackle
thank you
bye from App bye
bye that's
how